it's been a while since we've done some
voicemails do you guys want to stop
bickering
and stop playing
slap ass
i see what you're doing let's see can i
just say sona tried to grab my water
and read the label i didn't like the
intrusion so i went to just give her a
little bing
with my pen just a little swat that's my
pen no one likes a tattletail yeah
snitches get stitches yeah snitches get
stitches or they get lightly tapped with
a pen okay let's go okay we're gonna do
a voicemail we haven't done this in a
while let's do a voicemail all right
eduardo hit it hi conan my name's arnold
i was wondering if it's possible to be
intermittently funny sometimes i nail it
and i think about comedy and like to do
it but other times it just falls flat
you know
but
i was also wondering last spring dug
myself this little poncho got the
tractor halfway stuck in it's a good old
78 international home still not figuring
out how to pull that out but you get
ideas there's my number here all right
bucko
uh there's no way this is a real person
that is not a real person
i think it's not a real person um
whoever you are my hat's off to you uh
fantastic performance
no
now cool and i'm wounded what are you
talking about
bucko now that they're my 78
international
no well what if it is now you've hurt
his feelings i know
no listen first of all uh
no one's funny all the time well that's
not true there are exceptions
uh but everyone's intermittently funny
even the the greats the greats are
intermittently funny no one's funny all
the time
um and sir if this really is you and you
are a real person what did he say his
name was
yeah
not a real person i just don't buy it do
you
i i'm very gullible i believe everything
i don't think it's a real person you
guys don't think so
i so i listen to 700 voicemails and i
can tell i feel like i have a good sense
now of what's fake and what's not yeah i
think arnold's real i agree
i've heard a lot of people try i i have
heard a lot of voicemails of people
putting on an affect or whatever i and i
feel like it occurred to me that he
might be fake but ultimately when i
listen i think he's real can we start
listening to it again and then eduardo
when i give you a signal stop it so i
can give different notes here we go hey
conan my name's arnold i was wondering
if it's possible to be intermittently
funny sometimes i nail it
and i think about comedy and like to do
it but other times it just falls flat
you know
but
i was also wondering last spring dug
myself this little poncho got the
tractor halfway stuck in it's a good old
78 international home that's the part
that i think is fake no that that's the
part i was in i was okay with it i was
suspicious but in but then he brings up
for no reason he crams in this thing
about
he says i was thinking and then he
brings up i got my my tractor stuck the
old 78 international
and digging myself a hole is that a real
tractor
yes
but
i'm not buying that part no i believe it
i believe it
i think i like to think that there's a
guy named arnold somewhere who's wearing
overalls and listening to this podcast
and he's
he likes to think he's funny and he
looks up to you as a comedy person well
listen i'm not trying to hurt anyone's
feelings but i'm telling you as a
professional
i had a show and one of the main uh
one of the main
comedic staples of my show was me being
interrupted by kooky characters
halfway through
um after the first guest for years
thousands of them
and they sound like this guy i
understand your suspicion but and i mean
my i had a flag raised too but
ultimately it still feels on the real
side me too yeah i think he's real how
do we find out can we find out can we
call him i guess we have his we have his
number we can call him can we call him
yeah
hello you've called the home of noted
voice and character actor
charles winthrop charleston voice of
character actor and tractor collector an
enthusiastic and
tractor aficionado
charles charleston charles
what's this oh you're looking for oh
arnold is it well hold on a second
gargle gargle gargle
way way way
uh i'll also say before we call him uh
this this voicemail is like from like
february so he called a long time ago
i think if if there's a third call
people will take it seriously otherwise
he's just unavailable yeah you know it
goes straight to voicemail right your
call has been forwarded to an automated
voicemail well let's leave a message at
the tone please record your message when
you finish recording you may hang up or
press one for more options
hello arnold this is conan o'brien
calling from the podcast conan o'brien
needs a friend i got your message
i have some questions for you
i hope you're well
don't worry about being intermittently
funny that's all of us
i just want to chat with you briefly
about the old 78
international
i'm a bit of a tractor fan
so please call me back
yes tell them he can text us that number
you can text us to this number and we'll
get in touch with you
yes interested to have a little talk
yes
you're a good guy over and out
okay well we hope to have more on this
in a later segment yeah yeah i'm very
and listen uh arnold i
i don't mean to impugn you in in any way
it's just that when you start to go on
about the harvester i mean the
international
78 tractor i it felt like you were
it felt to me
like you were piling on a little bit
like you were really trying to give it
an extra dose of the good old
country feller and that's
to me felt
like maybe you're doing a voice see i
thought he was a a real person who does
want to be funny and works with tractors
and thought it might be funny if i name
check something super specific yeah but
what in what context does he bring up
the tractor exactly he's funny he's
going non-secondary he's going out of
context okay you are thinking about it
way too much
i'm with i'm with gorly i think that he
knows what he sounds like and he's like
i i'm digging a pond and my tractor fell
in it and that's really funny and i
agree it is really funny that the
tractor fell i find i think it's sad a
78 international that's a great old
tractor and i'm sorry that his tractor
felon got wet i don't know anything
about trucks adam you're with me right
i'm not alone on this if it's worth
anything i looked up his area code 707.
and it's uh
in cal it's a california
area oh where in california if it's
central california we're still in
business the 707 area code serves the
cities of american canyon arcada venetia
rural agricultural california yeah
tractor land usa
i still pond i don't know
possibly possibly well that wasn't
really a californian rural accident that
was like i know that's the other thing
that is
first of all he sounds like he's
narrating an old southern story doesn't
he well you know
puts me in mind of an old tale i mean
he should be
you know what i mean he's arnold call us
and don't fake
don't fake it tell us for real call back
and let us know please arnold yes thank
you arnold we'll continue this later to
be continued